[Music]
joseph is with us joseph is in dallas
texas hi joseph how are you
hey dave i'm doing very well
good what's
up i love the show i've been listening
to your podcast
for the last several months
i wanted to ask your thoughts about
making the decision
uh
my wife and i i'm currently working uh
she's been a stay-at-home mom for the
last uh five and a half years
and uh her former boss reached out to
her
to ask if she would be interested in
coming back to work um and we have a
two-year-old and a five-year-old
um so the boys are getting ready to
start preschool uh and kindergarten
and so the timing of it seems like it
might make sense but i was interested
what your thoughts were as far as
making the decision to go from staying
at home to uh you know to working
parents
yeah
well there's nothing wrong with it um
lots of working parents are great
parents
um it's not it doesn't require you stay
home to be a good mom
um but there's also nothing wrong with
deciding i want to stay home and spend
my time on my kids
so there's uh you know people get judged
for either one i can tell you that um
but not here right i i i'm gonna support
you either way whatever you decide to do
uh what i what i wouldn't so so i'm not
gonna throw a blanket on this and go oh
well she must go back to work or oh no
she can't go back to work i would never
do that that's not i think the question
is how much are they going to pay her
a lot more than me
how much
uh
and fifteen thousand okay pretty
tempting then huh
uh yeah yeah attempting to hurt the
biggest
yes i mean we're both excited at the
opportunity we're baby step two right
now so we'd be able to become debt free
very quickly like by the end of next
year and the trade-off is what have the
what's the trade-off what's the loss
time with time with our kids uh having
to hire you know a nanny or daycare uh
to take care of them uh that's the
primary things
okay
well the two-year-old from two to five
you're never going to get those years
back uh but there's certainly nothing
wrong with
uh again having daycare having a nanny
uh having after school care whatever the
process is people do it every day and uh
it's it's not immoral it's not wrong
you're not a bad parent um
but you've just got to decide okay what
kind of boundaries can i put on this i
mean this guy's wanting to work 40 hours
not 80 right
yes correct that's a boundary number one
uh then uh i don't know maybe there's
some flexibility around
school time about when she shows up or
when she doesn't show up at the office
right
yeah
especially now
uh their
work from home i think 50 percent of the
time so well that's a big deal she's
going to be at home 50 percent of the
time
oh wow okay so she we're only talking
about
two and a half days or two days a week
of problem then right
right
uh
who watches the kid while at home while
she's working
nanny
yeah we we don't know that yet we just
have to find somebody well i think what
you got
if sharon and i are doing this decision
we have to put down
exactly how this is going to go down and
then look at that and say we're trading
that for 115 000 bucks
that's a trade
is it a good trade and if it's a good
trade we'll do the trade um
you know and lots of people look up and
they go the trade is not worth it um my
wife desperately wants to be at home
full-time with the kids and not work and
there's not really any amount of money
that is you can put on the other side of
that scale that makes it tip and so then
they choose to stay home and there's
nothing wrong with that and there's
nothing wrong with going dadgum this is
quite honoring an old boss from five
years ago calls up and offers us the
brinks truck let's this is on that's
honoring to her it says a lot about who
she is right
absolutely which is that that's a nice
compliment it makes it really tempting
as well because they obviously have huge
respect for her
so
good stuff good stuff
there's not a right or wrong answer
brother but i would get down and say
this is our life is currently x
if we do this exactly what does our life
look like change
exactly what are we going to do exactly
how we're going to handle it
then you know the trade you're making
because you're trading 115 000
for whatever stress or absenteeism or uh
time away from the kids you're putting
on the table and if it's minimal away
from the kids
you know it's really tempting to look at
really tempting